hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again we
have another dead stream and we got some
interesting news to talk about and it's
a funny thing to mention at the end of
the at the end of the video but
regardless it was a slow news day today
but that doesn't really matter because
we still had some interesting info being
talked about and that info being we're
going to be getting lots of info on
everything about the training Charles
mode and arena mode next week as well as
them showcasing the new duel and brawl
maps which is supposed to be the arena
for each of the factions lack
compensation for PC and very much more
coming next week so definitely stay
tuned to the channel to be caught up on
all that info since I'll gladly recap
that for all of you next upload Dan said
death was delayed sadly because of a bug
found in the game with the respawn
system so that we're at least next week
as opposed to today it was supposed to
come out
April 5th sadly but like I said that'll
be out next week Congrats to the Knights
on PC and Xbox and the Vikings for on
ps4 for winning the Vanquisher rush
community event so grab your awards
while you can also congrats to the
Vikings for clean sweeping the faction
war the season you guys will be getting
your rewards at the end of the season
hopefully the ornaments and anything
that they happen to throw at you guys
will be good and worth it the content of
the week is actually a new effect and
it's gonna be called Hell's Gate and it
has this lava pool underneath the player
I personally think it's better as an
idol effect than opposed to an emo or
execution but I wish the execution
version would have huh would have hands
come out of the ground and grab the
player and bring him down under either
way though that's going to be costing
you 5,000 steal if you're interested and
then the last bit of info in terms of
the news if you're watching the street
before on our dev stream on April Fool's
you know that they were doing this thing
as type of an April Fool's joke and
that's what you're gonna be seeing on
screen we the community had to type in
the commands at the bottom to defeat the
other cowl player and a best of 99
rounds it's literally warden but just
skinned as a cow I thought it was really
funny we eventually came out on top and
it was incredibly fun to watch and
participate with everybody I will show
some of the fights for the rest of the
video you can go to the for honor reddit
if you want to see all ninety nine
rounds think it's like a 20 minute video
but it's really a lot of fun and it was
definite it was really funny and
definitely unexpected from the devs to
pull this off on April Fool's but now
that we're done with that I leave you
guys a question
what new emote or what new execution
would you guys want in the game specify
the character or what emote slice
execution would that
for example I could say that I want a
new emo where there's a bunch of
lightning that comes out of nowhere I
know we have something similar to that
but a lot more powerful and then maybe
there could be a new execution for
gladiator where maybe he like whips that
ridin atom similar to how a shaman whips
our axe at them kind of like with the
Trident and just stabs him in the back
of it and then rips it out stuff like
that
specify the character and then tell me
about the emote and execution and what
would that be I would love to know your
thoughts I love starting up a discussion
but that's going to be the end of the
video today guys hope you guys did enjoy
this picture got a little bit more info
this time as opposed to the other two
couple weeks so I'm very happy about
that but yeah as I said like the video
if you guys did enjoy this help me out
subscribe it for new I got tons of new
400 content coming of course there's
gonna be stuff next week but I cover the
news the leaks the info the patch notes
all the information outside a foreigner
I like to cover and if you guys could I
really don't ask this a lot but if you
guys could hit the bell next to the
subscription bar that would be amazing
YouTube's doing this stupid ass [ __ ]
again where they're [ __ ] over me and
other people of course I guess people
aren't getting other youtubers videos in
their sub boxes even if they're subbed
which may have which may have happened
to some of you guys I'm not entirely
sure but if that's the only way to
counteract that is if you hit the
subscription button and the notification
bell so you can get them both in your
sub box and your notifications
it's absolutely [ __ ] and I don't
know why this is a thing but just hit
that just in case you missed one of my
videos on accident and then my two most
recent videos going to be on screen if
you guys want to check those out I'm at
that guys hope you have a great Esther
day and peace out